- So you fell from a bike, like again.
So like what, why do you
keep getting on bikes?
- The assassin.
(Kelly laughs)
- It wasn't me.
- [Kelly] How are you feeling?
- Ever since Sofia joined the
show, we've all had accidents.
- [Kelly] Wait, is this true?
- Yep.
- They say that, but I don't believe it,
because nothing has happened to me.
- [Simon] One by one.
- I haven't even, in
two years, gotten COVID.
Not even once, so I don't know.
- Oh, you girl, you better be knocking
on that wood right now.
I'm knocking for you.
- [Terry] Yeah!
(audience clapping)
- I don't know why he
blames me for everything.
- [Simon] I'm just saying.
- Wait, so what happened to y'all?
Did something happen to y'all?
- Well, one by one,
we've all had accidents
ever since Sophia joined the show.
Howie's not here.
- I mean, it is kind of true.
When Sophia came the first year we met,
the next day, I was sick.
- [Sofia] She was sick.
- [Simon] I was ill. Then I broke my back.
- I mean, they say that I was trying
to judge the whole show by myself.
(Terry and Kelly laughing)
- And host.
- And host. (laughs)
- Sofia's the only one left at the table.
(Simon laughing)
- Oh my gosh. I don't think
that you're a bad juju.
I think you're great juju.